you sing in the movie strange magic and
you have quite a good voice thank you
this is something that you like to do in
your personal life setting and my
karaoke person I am a huge character
person I actually have a karaoke lounge
in my basement I'll go to that alone
occasionally the karaoke lounge in your
basement with disco balls and write
Japanese business drinking glumly yes
but also but I have friends that just
will make me sing wherever I am you know
I'm friends with Robin right yes house
of cards yes yeah and wherever we are
she'll just make me sing we could be at
a bar or a hotel lobby or worse out
somewhere and there's a live band and
she will tell the singer to get off the
stage and she'll just put me up there
really so she sort of puts you in these
situations which could potentially be
embarrassing I would think potentially
yeah oddly enough it's really worked out
of my favorite there's actually a
YouTube video of me singing for her and
George Clooney at the Venice Film
Festival oh and she just shooed this
singer offstage and she put me up there
and I decided to sing four Non Blondes
what's up and it actually is that it's
the one that I want to trick you into
singing
[Applause]
[Applause]
I don't know the lyrics to anything so
it always becomes shava shava yeah as
long as you sell it it's fine when they
sing the national anthem I'm like Shah
Baba just keep confirming and denying
firmly deny fine yeah wait so you're
there and she made you go up and this is
the Venice Film Festival so it's very
public everyone's looking at you
everyone's looking you're probably
dressed up in a gown right and actually
have a bone to pick with George Clooney
because that night he said it was
tradition that you know the at the end
of the night the cast would jump into
the pool and so after I sang I was I was
kind of on this this high this
adrenaline rush so I went great let's do
it now and I jumped in the pool in my
gown and no one followed me I was trying
to get Paul Giamatti in and he was like
no so wait George Clooney kind of
promised you if you go I'll go yeah oh
no he said the whole cast was gonna do
it and I ended up in there alone but I
just went all whatever and I was like
having this amazing cathartic moment
floating in this pool and this gown and
then the security guards head just came
into frame and the moment was ruined and
I got in trouble and I got I got kicked
out embarrassing to be tasered in a pool
I think that's obvious to return that
dress to the designer and I don't think
they knew until probably right now that
that happened so right now they didn't
go back what it was they did no they got
it back so it's actually a testament to
how good the designer was but um because
they ruined it was
you